it's harvest time in indian-administered
kashmir where apple production
contributes 10 percent
to the state's 20 billion income
but this year apples are being left to
rot because farmers can't find people to
pick them
after prime minister narendra modi
abolished the state's autonomous status
and imposed a security lockdown
the situation is bad we couldn't harvest
the apples on time and most of them fell
down from the trees
now we're collecting the rotten apples
and throwing them away
internet and mobile phone services
remain cut off
for this farmer that means his business
is in jeopardy
when the basic communication is down we
are not able to
talk to the people uh no who were
sitting in delhi who are staying in
bangalore who are staying in
chennai and other big markets when we
are not able to communicate with them
it's really difficult this wholesale
fruit market in srinagar would normally
be packed with traders
businesses down by 95 per cent this year
compared to last
sssp each year i export about 200
000 boxes of apples in the domestic
markets across india
this year because of the situation
farmers aren't able to send their
produce to market
they don't know where to send it because
communication lines aren't working
in response to the crisis the indian
government has set up a national
cooperative through which farmers can
sell their produce
but it imposes strict quality control
measures
which many farmers find hard to meet
we can only select the produce if the
color of the apple is good
so far we have rejected 80 percent of
the farmers who've come here to sell
their produce
the apple industry in kashmir involves
3.5 million people
around half the population of the state
the lockdown has devastated the economy
and farmers are calling on the indian
government to immediately lift the
security restrictions
victoria gatenby al jazeera